mission impossible
fallout
des copies pis
de great de safran de greenpeace
bmo est fière
ce cas
[Musique]
après les gains des trois autres
ça passe
michel jusqu'à
sans cesse
dugo
m
il faut
notre destin maudit immigrés
rires
mais oui et où les seules
[Musique]
oui
joe mac os
[Musique]
mission impossible fallout
votre mission si toutefois vous
l'acceptez je me tais rage on avez vous
déjà reçu celle
[Musique]
la fin que vous redoutiez est proche
et c'est vous qui aurez ces morts sur la
conscience les conséquences de vos
bonnes intentions
[Musique]
vous avez pris une décision difficile à
berlin une vie perdue pour en sauver des
millions cette fois c'est le monde
entier qui est en danger c'est la
mission de la cia
s'il avait gardé le plutonium nous
n'aurions pas cette conversation toute
son équipe seraient mortes
oui probablement ce sont les risques du
métier
[Musique]
tu ne sais pas de quoi tu t'es engagé tu
ferais mieux de temps là les s'il te
plaît non pas contre toi combien de fois
hunt at il été trahi par son
gouvernement désavoué mis sur la touche
combien de temps un homme comme lui
peut-il supporter ça avant de décider
que ça suffit
ça ne nous ressemble pas utile
peut-être qu'il est temps que ça change
[Musique]
alors comment il va tu sais comme on les
aime
qu'est ce qu'il fait je crois qu'il vaut
mieux pas regardé